what is embodied cognition it's actually
the idea that the body and the mind work
together and that our bodily feelings
our physical sensations influence our
thoughts our decisions our behaviors our
emotions and what is more important
often without our awareness in other
words the temperature of the things we
touch the texture of the things we touch
the colors we see everything that we
feel through our senses affect us not in
in the most obvious way but in in in
ways that we could not have imagined I
know that most people don't realize how
major effect they have on our life and
it is important because if you walk in
the street or if you touch something or
the way I am sitting now and it's soft
or our chair or the distance between me
and the camera
all these influence the way people
perceive me and I perceive others and as
a consequent
the way we behave and once we know it we
can be less manipulated by these
physical experiences and maybe come to
more judgments that are based on the
real issue rather than on things which
are actually irrelevant in a way
so we all know that we use metaphors we
say somebody is the warm person I had a
heavy decision I had a hard day a rough
day we had a smooth sailing if you
notice what do we do we take a concrete
concept and we use it to describe more
abstract concept we say somebody is a
warm person so we take a concrete
concepts such as a warm temperature and
to describe a personality which is more
an abstract concept or we say I had a
rough day we use the texture raff that
we all know what it is to describe
something more abstract metaphors are
not just figures of speech they are more
than that they are part of the process
of understanding a concepts in our
cognitions and I can start with the
temperature to show to show this effect
and then I'll go along all the other
senses
temperature let's start with temperature
we touch warm and halt and cold things
all the time we hold our coffee or iced
coffee beverages we take a bath or
shower we go to the swimming pool we
touch all the signs all the time holding
cold things how do they affect us so as
I said before we use a term a warm
personality warm hearted etc two
researchers from Yale University
Wiedemann barged decided to examine what
is the meaning of this metaphor whether
it's it has more than just figures
speech so what I did was they invited
participants to their laboratory and
when each participant came to the lab it
was accompanied by an experimenter to
the fourth floor in the elevator
what expert the participants didn't know
is that the experiment actually started
in the elevator because the experimenter
had her hands full and at a certain
point she asked each participant could
you hold my cup of coffee for a minute
for me while I'm writing your name now
for half of the participants she handed
a cold cup of coffee and iced coffee for
the other half she handed a warm cup of
coffee that's all then she took her cup
of coffee back then they came to the lab
immediately after that and they were
asked to judge a person they never knew
about certain characteristics the
amazing result was that those who held a
cold cup of coffee in the elevator judge
that person is less warmer considering
personality and then those who held a
warm cup of coffee in other words those
who held a warm cup of coffee judge that
person is a nicer person a friendlier a
warm-hearted person compared to those
who held a cold cup of coffee now these
researchers wanted to find out whether
it's not only affecting judgment of
others but actual behavior so in a
second experiment they told participants
that they are participating in a
marketing study where they had to hold
for Fuels minutes at a Polock paid half
of the subject held a warm pair apart
fed the other half a cold therapeutic
pet and there were as some questions
about the product as if it was a
marketing study and then they were I
were offered as a reward for their
participation either to choose either a
gift for themselves or a gift for a
friend those who held a warm therapeutic
pad chose more often a gift for a friend
then a gift for themselves and more
often chose a but more important they
chose more often
it gives for a friend and those who held
a called therapeutic faith in other
words it affected their generosity if I
take all these together that just the
touch of something warm or cold affected
the way we perceive others the way we
behave in the way we trust others think
about how these implications have so
many implications in real-life situation
when you interact whether it's a
business negotiation or whether you
interact with your friends with your
family with your children with your
spouse with your boss whatever you
definitely want that the other person
will perceive you is a nicer person you
definitely want that person to be more
generous and trust you more
you